es geht es sonst noch in einer stadt
sich ihr museum nicht mehr leisten kann
oder will besucherzahlen subventionen
abbaut
was darf die kunst kosten die diskussion
wird unbarmherzig geführt
beispiel olten dem kunstmuseum droht das
ende
seit januar herrscht ausgabestopp eine
bereits geplante ausstellung wurde
abgesagt in die bresche springen 30
schweizer museen
sie helfen dem kunstmuseum und seiner
direktoren mit leihgaben
das ist eine unglaubliche solidarität in
kirchschlag thema für deren ständige
frühling aufbruch auf nick jugend also
alles das wo man eben mit jessica
verbinden parameter jetzige situation
von hus hoffen müssen alle drei oltner
museen stehen sie doch auf dem prüfstand
das budget der stadt reicht nicht mehr
für alles seit der größte steuerzahler
der energiekonzern alpiq schwächelt sein
vorstoß im oltner parlament löste die
debatte aus der grünliberale simon
haller träumt wie andere auch von einer
nutzung mit mehr rendite
jetzt besserte sich zurücklehnen und
suchen jahren und kennt sie die stadt
rund 690 franken seien ermögliche
rechten macht ist es absurd dass man
mich die nutzungen noch erreicht was man
als abschluss macht das gastro betrieb
mit endlicher werbliche nutzung
alles luftschlösser was fehlt ist eine
definition welche kultur die stadt will
so sieht es die gruppe pro kultur
wollten ihr ziel das kunstmuseum in der
heutigen form zu retten koste frankfurt
die knapp und überall gespart
lehrer überhaupt wenn das nicht
es ist bereits sein spektrum abdeckt von
relativ geringes startgeld zu kämpfen
diskussionslos alles kunst
dem widerspricht pius knüsel ehemaliger
direktor der kulturstiftung pro helvetia
ohne reduktion der kulturangebote drohe
der kultur infarkt so sein befund vor
zwei jahren
nun da die geldflüsse vielerorts stoppen
sieht er sich bestätigt dank es gibt es
verschärfte konkurrenzsituation
frauenvertreterin institutionen enormen
schwäche
da muss man sich überlegen wie viel
linie für 13 überhaupt und mit ihrem
besten sind jederzeit das größere mit
dem kopf besser bestanden
auch in winterthur gerät grad mancher
stein ins wanken große sparübungen
gefährden den ruf als museumsstadt
beispiel museum oskar reinhart am
stadtgarten spätestens in zwei jahren
geht der sammlung der handels familie
reinhardt das stiftungsvermögen aus was
dann mit caspar david friedrichs
berühmtem bild der kreidefelsen auf
rügen und den anderen 500 werken
passiert ist offen
nun werden die argumente gewetzt warum
die sammlung unbedingt hier bleiben muss
reinhard einmalig ist die wichtigste
sammlung von peter kunz zwischenruf
klaric und der frühen moderne außerhalb
von deutschland und sechs gruppen steht
sammler schweizer reha-zentrum wald
liegt sind in einer sehr schwierigen
situation und zwar was zukunftsweisend
museum wie diese überhaupt besteht
gummi sind drei schaffen dass wir
lösungen finden sind auf allen ebenen
prekärer noch ist die situation bei der
winterthurer villa flora ab ende april
ist betriebsschluss auf unbestimmte zeit
weil die subventionen der stadt
ausbleiben
noch einmal sind die besten stücke der
sammlung harmloser ausgestellt bevor sie
nach hamburg und paris ausgeliehen
werden
alles keine räumliche situation für den
stadtpräsidenten michael künstler winter
hält er ist zwar immer sehr viel näher
an der vielfalt durch die immer
überlastet sind wobei 90 kulturstadt
daraus macht und ich bin der meinung das
angebot von hand dass wir die zukunft
daran nicht nur die öffentliche raum
mittragen der beruf und privat die
unterstützung bereits geschlossen sind
die hallen für neue kunst in
schaffhausen
die stiftung ist konkurs ein
rechtsstreit um die installation das
kapital von joseph beuys ging verloren
mit hohen prozesskosten
offen ist wie es nun weitergeht mit
diesem avantgardistischen kunsttempel
des umtriebigen künstlers groß raus
müller in olten machen derweil die
direktorin katja herlach und dorothee
meßmer das haus bereit für den frühling
wer hier noch einmal alles neu machen
soll